after more than 48 hours of counting
votes some of the midterm election races
are still not settled Democrats and
Republicans are battling out in Arizona
in Florida ed O'Keefe is tracking those
races from Capitol Hill and good morning
good morning nor there are about 20 big
races nationwide that are still
undecided in Arizona in that big Senate
race there are still more than 300
thousand ballots yet to be counted but
overnight the Democrat Kyrsten Sinema
pulled into the lead ahead of Republican
martha mcsalley
if cinema prevails she'd be the first
Democrat to win in Arizona Senate seat
since 1988 down in Florida the state's
two big races are too close to call
Democrat Senator Bill Nelson trying to
hold on to his seat and is calling for a
recount he trails Republican Rick Scott
by a little more than 15,000 votes or
just get this point 1 percent of the
total vote in the governor's race
Democrat Andrew Gilliam might have taken
back his concession yesterday his
campaign saying it's clear there are
more uncounted ballots than previously
reported Gilliam is still trailing the
Republican Ron De Santis
but only by about 36,000 votes here in
Washington Democrats pleased they are
still on pace to pick up more than 30
seats in the House of Representatives
gale all right the story continues there
thank you ad